thomas bonsoir pour quelles raisons
cette mesure suscitait la controverse
et bien tout est parti d'un article
publié par le wall street journal selon
leurs informations
l'administration de joe biden est en
discussion pour procéder à des
dédommagements financiers pour les
familles de migrants qui ont été
séparées qui se trouve donc d'un côté et
de l'autre de la frontière américaine
c'est une des conséquences de la
politique de tolérance zéro et qui était
en vigueur sous la présidence de donald
trump des parents ayant traversé
illégalement la frontière américaine ont
été expulsés tandis que leurs enfants
eux se trouvent toujours aux états unis
alors des plaintes ont été déposées au
niveau fédéral ces derniers mois par les
avocats de ces familles qui travaillent
conjointement avec des associations de
défense des droits de l'homme des
organismes qui alertait dès l'entrée en
fonction de joe biden à la maison
blanche de l'attention accordée à ce
dossier écouter
la nouvelle administration doit réunir
les familles séparées aux états unis
mais on ne peut pas s'arrêter là ces
familles méritent la citoyenneté des
ressources des soins et un engagement
que la séparation familiale ne se
reproduira plus jamais
alors le fait de verser de l'argent à
des milles et grands illégaux suscite
déjà la controverse aux états unis mais
ce qui choque le plus c'est en fait les
montants qui sont annoncés par cet
article du wall street journal toujours
selon leurs informations donc chaque
membre d'une famille ayant été séparé
pourrait toucher la somme de 450 milles
à dollars c'est un montant qui fait
bondir une partie des élus républicains
qui ont réagi à toute la journée ce
vendredi écouter
pure folie l'administration byden semble
envisager de payer 450 mille dollars aux
migrants illégaux qui ont délibérément
enfreint la loi c'est une claque en
plein visage pour nos citoyens
respectueux des lois qui se lèvent le
matin vont travailler et payent leurs
impôts
by john veut payer les migrants illégaux
450 mille dollars pour leurs souffrances
pendant qu'ils enfreignent nos lois pour
mettre ça en perspective si un militaire
est tué en opération sa famille reçoit
un versement de l'assurance de 400 mille
dollars je vous laisse y réfléchir
alors il est très difficile d'estimer
précisément combien de familles
pourraient être concernées mais
plusieurs milliers d'enfants isolées
auraient été identifiés par des
associations aux états unis on parle
donc potentiellement de plusieurs
millions de dollars qui pourraient être
distribués à ces familles du côté des
républicains beaucoup craignent que cela
envoie un mauvais message aux candidats
à la traversée illégale de la frontière
américaine qui on sait et déjà en proie
à une affluence record depuis maintenant
plusieurs mois merci beaucoup ton
abonnés en direct de washington